all right let's wrap up with something
trending on the Internet you may have
missed this is what I'm
[Music]
liking so it's not easy being a mama of
young kids and moving to a new city so
when Haley relocated from Houston to
Fort Worth she decided to form
connections by launching a little
Facebook group she called the weird
Mom's Club she thought she'd make maybe
a few friends that was five years ago
now she's got a whole Community around
her the group has thousands of members
and has even become a not for profit
which is incredible let's say hi to
Haley watching on nbc5 Dallas for worth
what's up
Haley what's up girl this is so sural
always nice to have a Tex on than you so
much for having me yeah absolutely how
did you get this started uh well like
you mentioned I uh relocated from
Houston to Fort Worth about 5 years ago
and my husband is from Fort Worth this
is his hometown and so he had all the
you know the friends and the family and
the connections and and they're great
people but they weren't my people um I
was a working mom still I am my kids
were a lot younger at the time they were
two and seven and so it was really hard
for me to get out and make those
connections for
myself uh so I ended up uh joining a
book club and hit it off with another
mom here and we joked like we're not
regular moms we're weird moms you know
because we have piercings and and we
don't like wine we like whiskey and we
don't like don't know kind a
stereotypical mom mold and we were
joking around and I said you know
there's got to be more moms like us
right especially here in Fort or created
the Facebook group and it's been five
years and now we have over 2,000 members
so explain how explain how it's a
nonprofit uh well the nonprofit so in
the the 2,000 plus members we have now
and we're moms I was really a lucky to
be able to find a group of women that I
can depend on and call them my family um
and so we started swapping clothes
amongst ourselves for our kids and
ourselves we kind of opened it up to
weird moms and so we went from swapping
with like 10 people to a thousand people
and then we were able to incorporate
found the nonprofit and really open it
up to the community so since April we've
distributed over 4,000 pounds of clothes
at no charge to almost 800 Shoppers here
in the area that is so
cool thank you girl was that I was that
kid who grew up in church like they'd
have like they'd collect you know bags
of clothes that you know hand me downs I
grew up on all that so that's so cool
because it's embarrassing for kids to
like show up in the same outfit every
day and not everybody has that that
money and especially when you have a lot
of kids in your household there a lot of
money so that's so cool what you're
doing it's it's got a really big impact
on on those kids lives at school too
socially speaking so thank you that's so
cool definitely Haley I'm liking your
post right
now all right well that's not all our
season long partner pilot pin makers of
precise the goto pin of the Kelly
Clarkson show want to celebrate those
bringing people together just like you
so they're going to give you $1,000
how's that
sound that should help a speechless you
thank you so much from one weird mom to
another thank you to all our guests
Michael V Alexa and Harry bird y'all
have a great day and if it's not try and
change
[Music]
[Applause]
it thank you guys y'all have a great
night I'm going
home